[Musique]
nous sommes en guerre 16 mars 2020 la
france s'apprête à vivre des semaines
éprouvantes les rues de la capitale
désertent l'école à la maison et des
hôpitaux proches de la saturation
votre meilleur moment matignon j'invite
venir le jour où je pourrai faire vous
savez la conférence presse quasi
hebdomadaires et où je pourrai dire à
mes concitoyens ça y est c'est fini vous
pouvez vous retracer dans un sûr que je
serais le premier heureux
il est dédé comment on fait les bébés
j'ai la bonne idée vous ah oui ça c'est
sûr et comme engrais je pense que je
vais plus dire sur le sexe d'accord très
bien fantasy par rapport au sexe mais je
sais que vous travaillez là dedans vous
avez quand même d'autres trucs qui vous
intéresse dans le cadre de la journée
j'ai 90 % de femmes accord très bien on
va essayer du coût devra mener sur les
10%
csdhi est en mode avion sont ceux
fournis et envoi d'avions depuis des
années c'est qu'il est en train de vivre
des moments uniques
je vous le dis les gens ont saisi est en
confinement depuis 1978 fait vrai mais
je le dis dans mes insurgés de l'est où
ses fruits s'est avérée vraie liste ces
voix là oui j'ai trop peur de souffrir
oui ça veut dire quoi être gitans ta vie
passée bien tous couchés tard pour
regarder la télé on est les rois work
engins pourquoi il a fait fi avec vous
là la fille et voudra pas qu'ils restent
fermées des garçons c'est mieux d'être
un garçon ou une fille
les filles ça nettoie sympathique en lui
un deal est tranquille et même si les
hommes qui commande
oui
[Applaudissements]
jean robert wife
j'ai repéré j'ai découvert une petite
photo de vous et c'est la gelée tels hp
sont les réseaux sociaux le 10 mai
c'est vrai que la cites la pole on
comprend pourquoi alors c'est à napoléon
le ghana mais sans déconner merci non
mais moi je suis un grand fan de dragon
ball z chez dragon ball z ticket dragon
ball z et parce que tu es un grand fan
de dragon veine mais je sais même pas le
dire le truc c'est pour te dire pourquoi
votre chamade mongol vous at-elle
surnommé shiko shiko noc ce qui veut
dire petit trou du cul parce que vous
étiez rétive malicieuse sceptiques
comment se fait-il surtout je n'arrêtais
pas de poser des questions parce que
évidemment on est confronté à des états
qu'on connaît pas on se voit en train de
faire des choses qu'on n'a pas décidé de
faire notamment pendant la transe qui
est un état dissociatifs et forcément on
pose des questions
emballé je devais faire une triste de
yamakasi guy pour m'éloigner parce que
la chanteraine briller dans la tête et
donc à force de poser des questions
auxquelles j'avais jamais de réponse est
toujours les esprits et enseignants
parce que pour eux c'est le vécu de la
transe qui va faire qu'on va comprendre
les choses c'est un peu si vous voulez
comprendre ce qu'est l'eau bas il faut
plonger dedans et puis voilà et donc là
c'est un peu la même chose et chaque
fois il m'énervait vraiment à répondre
les esprits tant seigneurie donc c'était
petit trou du cul tétouan et donc j'ai
mérité mon surnom de chichi que je
connais si comme le fait que les jeunes
prennent finalement le large a reculé
votre regard de charlie c'est pas tous
les soirs comme ça mais c'est une équipe
qui est créé des problèmes à pas mal de
personnes donc là on va le relever plein
infractions des nuisances sonores etc et
la consommation d'alcool encore
cette faiblesse elle était en moi le
monstre il est en moi et la vie
spirituelle ça m'a permis de me battre à
l'intérieur
maintenant je peux tolérer je peux
pardonner je peux aimer même sûrement
vous sentez bien maintenant un
complètement mais jamais dit beaucoup
par jour je médite six heures sept
heures par jour mais vous avez vraiment
les recettes n'ont tiré que vous avez
mangé doc gynéco l'homme alcoolisé sort
d'un bâtiment en travaux
escorté de près par les gendarmes le
gros porc croyez personne qui faisait
interpeller personne nous ramènera
l'agent avoir udr ai dit voilà les
gendarmes ou ramène monsieur le jeune
homme a perdu de sa superbe
vous cherchez vous trouvez un le groupe
des larmes en corée du sud à regarder
les images
les autorités ont choisi deux îles sur
place et ils ont décidé tout simplement
de tout repeindre en violet pourquoi et
bien pour faire plaisir aux touristes et
rendent les photos sur les réseaux
sociaux plus joli plus original c'est
vrai que sur instagram avait plus de
like avait dans une ville où tout les
repas ont violé regarder cette belle rue
c'est propre et island où il ya
vingt-huit mille mètres carrés de
toiture d'un violet triomphant que l'on
peut percevoir et discuter à leur père
se voir du ciel et puis à terre on voit
aussi des surfaces agricoles avec la
betterave ou encore de la lavande planté
comme ça au kilomètre même les habitants
ont décidé de ses biens en violet ya
même du riz violée si vous vous arrêtez
déjeuner alors ce projet a été lancé il
ya cinq ans est l'homme des guérini
téléphonie 4 millions $ 4 millions de
dollars pour pouvoir tout repeindre mais
ça marche
cinq cent mille touristes
supplémentaires en deux ans c'est une
plongée un peu étrange pour cet ours
polaires nous sommes bien loin de la
banquise
ici les rochers sont en plastique la
neige de la peinture
bienvenue à polar landes cet hôtel darby
nord-est de la chine a été spécialement
conçu pour exhiber aux clients les
mammifères
depuis cette chambre voici à quoi
ressemble la vue patinoire
r c'est long ça suffit ça des ca des
ponts alors oui respiration respiration
une femme et un homme qui joue de la
musique regarder l'un des dessins formé
par des dizaines de drones ou 8 des
drones ça s'est passé hier soir dans le
ciel de dublin à l'occasion de la
saint-patrick un spectacle grandiose
alors que toutes les célébrations de la
fête nationale ont été annulés pour la
deuxième année consécutive
[Musique]